hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Sherlock episode 1 video
Benedict Cumberbatch Doctor Strange is
back so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet there is a
Sherlock giveaway that I'm going to do
for each of the episodes I'm just going
to give away a copy of the DVD for any
season that you guys want so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a surah' related comment on
this video be sure to click that bell so
that you don't miss anything so I know
everything seems like it's lost Sherlock
and Watson or at odds it seems like
there's this rip between them that's
ever going to be healed we have the grim
specter of death in the form of Moriarty
in the poem that they keep repeating
through the episode things that you
can't outrun death is inevitable even
though as a child
Sherlock tried to write it a different
way the person went to a different City
and tricked death so that's the idea of
this new series will Sherlock be able to
change the story so to speak and defeat
Moriarty a final time even after his
death because I don't think that they're
trying to assert that he's still alive
Sherlock's convinced that he's dead but
that he's left him a game posthumously
like there is one final game that will
be the greatest game that Moriarty said
in motion knowing that he was getting
ready to die back in season 2 so that's
sort of like the overarching storyline
they really only touch on it at the
beginning of the episode and then again
at the end of the episode like every
once in a while you're reminded about it
through the poem but mostly this is a
story about the six thatcher's which is
a reference to the classic Holmes story
the adventure of the six Napoleon's so
there are like busts of Napoleon that
keep getting smashed six busts in all
the people that get murdered along the
way were the names that they used in the
episode so they almost did that exact
same storyline but obviously the TV show
we've that in with Mary's backstory that
was a change from the classic Holmes
story and in the original story they
weren't looking for a thumbdrive
obviously you're talking about like
1900s they were looking for the Black
Pearl that was hidden in one of the
Napoleon busts so in this episode
Sherlock thinks that that is what AJ is
after he thinks that he's after the
Black Pearl and that's why he's going
around to all these places trying to
smash all the busts and killing the
people so the important thing about that
is just to remember that they did not
solve the case of the black
Perle it's still out there that might
end up weaving in with the larger
Moriarty plot later on like there are
always times in Sherlock episodes where
you think that the different cases all
weave together sometimes they seem like
they're not connected but then over the
course of the three episodes they make
more sense even though within each
episode they might not necessarily be as
connected as you think so what about
Toby Jones the person that we saw in all
the trailers we didn't see him anywhere
in this episode he's really like the new
big bad of season four in the way that
Magnussen was the villain of season
three in that Moriarty was the big
villain before that although technically
Moriarty is always going to be the
biggest villain even when he's dead so
we'll see how Toby Jones characters
connected to that but we don't know who
he's playing yet they haven't revealed
that we'll probably meet him in the
second episode and then in the third
episode just as his tradition with the
series you get your final big mystery to
connect all of the episodes you know
technically each of the episodes is kind
of standalone with like a loose plot
like this Moriarty plot that gets strung
out over the three and it really doesn't
come together till the third episode so
like whatever the plot is with Toby
Jones that'll have something to do with
Moriarty's final game as Sherlock
believes it but it was a 90 minute
episode so it was packed full of Easter
eggs from all across the Sherlock Canon
from the TV movies from the classic
Holmes stories so I've already explained
the six Thatcher's Easter Egg the Black
Pearl Easter egg
but when Sherlock says that he's just
going to wait for Moriarty's game to
present itself to him like I'm just
going to start solving cases just like I
normally would so during that montage
they flashed all that text of all the
cases up on the screen those are all
Easter eggs for different Holmes stories
so the dusty death case is a reference
to Sherlock Holmes and the jeweler of
Florence the dusty death is a line
inside the book but the book itself is
quoting Macbeth in the line is all our
yesterday's have lighted fools the way
to dusty death so that in and of itself
sort of loops back around to the idea
that you can't outrun your past there
are consequences Mary's death was a
consequence of the way she lived she
wasn't able to outrun death it's
inevitable so we're like Inception
third-level deep Easter eggs here the
thumb with the bag of ice in it is a
reference to a short story called the
adventure of the engineers thumb in fact
most of these other case
is that I'll mention are probably from
the Sherlock Holmes short stories so the
duplicate man I think is a reference to
the adventure of the dancing men which
is one of the short stories the circus
torso I think is a reference to the
adventure of the veiled lodger which is
another short story the canary trainer
is actually a short story by Nicholas
Meyer which is actually more recently so
that wasn't written by Conan Doyle but
the jellyfish case like where they joke
about trying to arrest a jellyfish is a
reference to the adventure of the lion's
mane which is another one of the short
stories in which someone gets murdered
and it turns out the culprit is a lion's
mane jellyfish in the elaborate case
that he details when he's talking to the
man whose wife has left him sounds a
little bit like Sherlock Holmes in the
voice of terror which is actually like a
1942 film based on the story his last
bow which itself was used as inspiration
for the title of series 3's finale his
last vow which was also important in
this episode - so if you forgot the vow
that was actually series 3 episode 2 his
last vow was to protect Mary the baby
and Watson like their Trinity like the
Holy Trinity with his life so in his
grief Watson now blames Holmes for
breaking his vow allowing Mary to die so
as is the case in the past sometimes
they'll have like a big time jump
between episodes
so like episode 2 might not pick up in
the moments at the end of this episode
like we might be a couple months down
the road so of course we think that
Watson and Holmes will mend the rift
somehow Sherlock will find a way to
uphold the terms of his vow to marry you
know promise me that you will save John
Watson but in doing so like we've seen
in the trailer like you see Watson down
here in the well Silence of the Lambs
style it puts the lotion on his skin
it's just going to test the limits of
what Sherlock is capable of and it all
comes back around to what Mycroft was
telling him about how sentiment is such
a bad thing how it's going to get him in
trouble down the line he definitely came
off like a real villain when he was
trying to ask him about Agra like what
is this thumbdrive was your involvement
with them did you use this assassins
group for a little while during that
scene I actually thought that Mycroft
was going to be the one to have betrayed
them until we learned that it was
actually the receptionist who was just
upset about the life that she chose
not to lead so the whole metaphor here
is that Watson is like slowly turning
into this old lady so Sherlock has to
save him from his grief so that he can
come back out and live a full normal
life but as is the case with most
Sherlock episodes is packed with Easter
eggs it was amazing you can definitely
tell they took their time building this
script it's just like so packed with
stuff you could watch this a couple
times and find even more Easter eggs
speaking of which the dog the dog was
great it's kind of a metaphor for
Redbeard which is sort of the in
Sherlock's emotional armor just proving
that he's not a psychopath he is a human
with human emotions
Redbeard was his dog as a child they
flash back to it whenever he got knocked
out by Mary in the episode so presumably
something really bad happened to the dog
and it died and it just tore him apart
so every time he remembers it now he
just goes a little bit nuts
but speaking of chinks in the armor so
Mary's death very emotional now Sherlock
is in therapy just like Watson was in
therapy at the beginning of the series
way back in season 1 so Watson we also
have to talk about that WTF affair that
he had during the episode I will
understand if you think it was complete
garbage but I feel like they did that
for him just to make him feel like he
didn't have the moral high ground like
to complicate his character so that he
had his own secrets he was keeping from
everyone else just like Mary had her
secrets and Sherlock has his own secrets
so the only other like real big thing to
remember for next week's episode is the
sticky note on Mycroft's fridge 13th he
calls someone we don't know who it is
but it seems rather ominous like he's
setting something in motion so that'll
probably carry forward in the next
week's episode so if you didn't know
episode 2 is going to air next week
episode 3 the week after that so it'll
be like one episode each Sunday after
this so if you spotted any in the
episode that I didn't mention just write
them below in the comments but what's
going to happen is is episode 2 will air
next week then episode 3 will air the
week after that so I will do a giveaway
each week and then tomorrow what's going
to happen is is I'll do like a 2017
video for like all the big stuff that
I'm going to be doing videos for the
next month or two the exciting stuff
that's coming up that you guys should be
really hype about so it's going to be
awesome
starting off 2017 right yay Sherlock is
back where you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for like my big
Sherlock playlist and you can click here
to learn all about the new DC Comics TV
show that's
coming this year thank you so much for
watching everybody what's that five I'll
see you guys tonight